[Musique]
décapotable customiser ou taillés pour
le circuit plus de 200 coccinelle expose
fièrement leurs chromes des cox bichonné
par des passionnés de tout âge à 19 ans
sony a restauré la sienne avec son père
il est aujourd'hui le plus heureux des
jeunes conducteurs
elle est ou tard on dit c'est mignon
comme tout comme bagnole
on rigole tout le temps et ce qui me
fait plus plaisir c'est que quand tu
croises les gens et organes ils ont le
sourire tout automatiquement et si ses
formes arrondies lui ont permis de ne
pas prendre une ride la voiture du
peuple a réussi un exploit devenir un
symbole pour plusieurs générations
elle a traversé les années 70 avec le
flower power qui était la mise en valeur
de la wac coccinelle et le truc qui a
fait que la coccinelle elle est
extraordinaire c'est le film de walt
disney parce que le walt disney il a 53
ans cette année
car la star des rassemblement de
coccinelles c'est bien sûr choupette
laurent a fait le déplacement d'auxerre
pour présenter cette réplique réalisée
dans les moindres détails
j'ai fait la trappe à essence et
l'anecdote du film à monte carlo c'est
le diamant qui est dans le réservoir de
la choupette voilà
ce qui m'étonne c'est que vraiment des
enfants de 8 ans la connaissent déjà les
films me disent qu'à l'issue afin qu
elles il ya les chouettes et puis voilà
quoi donc qu'ils avaient qu'ils ont
adoré les films et qui sont contents
d'en voir une en vrai quoi donc voilà et
c'est vrai que ça s'arrête de gaza
des centaines de passionnés qui
reprendront ce soir la route sous la
chaleur l'astucieuse climatisation
naturelle de la coccinelle elle aussi
reste dans le vent
ma